(button clicking)
(reels whirring)
- This hit
(speaker feedback ringing)
goes out to you, Mr. Wick.
♪ Woke up this morning ♪
- 42 regular, wasn't it?
- Yeah.
♪ You got yourself a gun ♪
- And so it begins.
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah. ♪
♪ You got yourself a ♪
(air whooshing)
♪ I'm livin' in this
time behind enemy lines ♪
♪ So I got mine, I hope you ♪
♪ Got yourself a gun ♪
- Challenge him to single
combat.
- If you win, you will have your
freedom.
♪ And when I see you I'ma
take what I want so ♪
(man screaming)
- Amen.
♪ Yeah ♪
(weapon firing rapidly)
♪ You ain't real, hope ya ♪
♪ Got yourself, yourself ♪
♪ Y'all feel the wrath of a
killer ♪
(drums beating rapidly)
(static buzzing)
(drums beating)
♪ You got yourself, yourself,
yourself ♪
(drums beating)
♪ Many try, many die ♪
♪ If you want a war ♪
♪ Get it bloody ♪
(drums beating)
♪ Woke up this morning ♪
(tires screeching)
(cars thudding)
[Killa] The Baba Yaga.
(chuckling)
[Caine] Come on.
♪ You got yourself ♪
[The Elder] The only way John
Wick will ever have freedom...
♪ You got yourself, yourself ♪
and peace...
is in death.
(music swells)
(horse neighing)
(drumbeat and silence)
- Yeah, not really.
(drums beating)
(car horn blaring)
(gun firing rapidly)
(car horns blaring)
♪ Ah ♪
(dog barking)
♪ Yeah ♪
(dog growling)
(tires screeching)
(music swells)
♪ You got yourself a gun. ♪
(dog whimpering)
♪ Yeah ♪
(drums reverberating)